ولذا المراقبه
[Silence]
واف
مس
الد
خضرا
فيها في
النساء
الله
الله عليه
المراقبه
وتعالى
‏Best
سبحانه
انجين
[Silence]
‏I to you
sped the blood and up killing man from
the high in this
being headed by someone
موسى عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فخرج منها خائفا
يترقب
‏wasful
and
hyvil
you would
person that passed you that every
looking e that every
notion of a human being
‏here
المراقبه المراقبه
المراقبه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
هو الرقيب
الله الرقيب
الرقيب الرقيب
سبحانه وتعالى
قال الله تعالى الذي يراك حين تقوم وتقلبك
في الساجدين
‏number 21
[Silence]
وهو معكم اينما كنتم
سه
وقال تعالى ان الله لا يخفى عليه شيء في
الارض ولا في السماء
سوره ال عمران
الله
وقال تعالى ان ان ربك لبالمرصاد
سوره الفجر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى
بالمرصاد والمرصاد
من الرصد والترصد
[Silence]
الله
ان ربك لبصate
الله سبحانه وتالىر
name
‏as
of all the lord
of all
رب العالمين andcribes
himself
صلى الله عليه وسلم ربك
ربك
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ممد صل الله عليه
‏Your lord
is junction hees wa for those evilers
your lord
lord
what this me this me those who har the
prop
is
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ضمائر
الضمائر
والمضاف اليه في
‏in sciences
which is a study of the pronouns used in
the quan
articulates they all unite with one
or رب العالمين or رب محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم we say الرحمن الرحيم
الجبار المتكبر
سبحانه وتعالى
وقال تعالى
وقال تعالى يعلم
وهو يصف يصف نفسه سبحانه فهو يصف نفسه
فيقول عن نفسه يعلم اي الله يعلم خائنه
الاعين وما تخفي الصدور
number 19 غافر
‏e
ch con
the ean
what is spoken
is of course
included in this but even a flicker of
the eye
in treachery is
الله رب العالمين
يقول النووي والايات في الباب كثيره
معلومه
واما الاحاديث
‏icarnil
easy things
in certain times when a person for
instance goes to do something
‏etci
to have the foront of your mind all
time you time you
look
use eyes
ان ربك لبمرصاد
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يرزقنا
بمنه وكرمه وجوده حق المراقبه والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا